c'est lors de notre second débat débat
de société qui est consacrée à l'état de
nos prisons pour commencer je vous
propose de revenir sur l'une des
polémiques de l'été cet événement film
et collante est ce vous on a pu voir des
détenus faire du karting à fresnes
centre pénitentiaire également considéré
comme l'un des plus vétustes de
l'hexagone ya quelques jours deux
sénateur communiste du val de marne ont
décidé d'y faire usage de leur droit de
visite jérôme rabier les a accompagné
une visite surprise à fresnes après la
polémique hollandaise laurence cohen et
pascal savoldelli sénateur communiste du
val de marne n'en sont pas à leur
première venue et s'ils ne sont pas là
pour parler karting les activités
proposées aux détenus sont pour eux un
vrai sujet l'ancienne chapelle de la
prison transformée en salle des fêtes
est l'occasion d'un échange avec le
directeur de la prison il ya combien
événements par an
si on sort des fêtes religieuses
puisqu'elle est aussi c'est aussi aux
fêtes religieuses on va dire
hors jeu mais plausible qu'il
s'est trompé oui mais
les gens qui nous serons fiers ont
peut-être pas pour souvent d'ailleurs
parfois pas le à l'occasion de
participer par les moyens parfois d'y
participer
c'est aussi culturel souvent donc
messieurs poule quand on fait venir
en tout cas quelques éléments d'un
orchestre philharmonique
mais au delà des activités les
conditions de détention préoccupe les
sénateurs une visite en cellule s'impose
et si celle qu'il visite apparaît dans
un état correct le détenu présent leur
explique que ce n'est pas le cas partout
c'est là que les conditions sont très
bonnes
vissé à son tour
à noter tout de même un vrai progrès
plus aucune cellule de fresnes ne compte
plus de deux détenus alors que la brise
on a compté jusqu'à 2600 détenus pour
1300 places la période qu'ovide a fait
retomber les effectifs ils sont
désormais 1700 dans la prison pour
hommes la visite se poursuit dans les
parloirs où l'odeur d'humidité prend à
la gorge situé en sous sol c'est là que
les détenus peuvent voir leur avocat ou
leurs proches dans des conditions
terribles
mais c'est extrêmement exigu au niveau
du parloir
à la salle qui accueille soi-disant les
enfants elle fait elle fait flipper il
n'y a pas d'autre mot donc
dans ces conditions sanitaires
épouvantable parce que là
à l'humanisation moi ça m'a frappé en
2018 on laisse pas des enfants voir son
père sa mère voit la famille dans des
conditions comme ça si les murs sont
dans cet état c'est que freine attend
depuis longtemps une grande rénovation
mais les budgets ne sont toujours pas
voté un sujet dont les élus communistes
compte s'emparer à cette question des
travaux il ya un retard à réparer il
faut que dans la loi de finances pour le
budget 2023 il ya l'inscription d'été
centaines de millions qu'il faut pour
réhabiliter cette maison dans la prison
n'a plus vétustes de l'hexagone des
petits travaux ont été engagés mais tout
le monde est conscient que ces prisons
ouvertes depuis
1898 aura besoin de bien plus qu'un coup
de peinture
voilà pour ce reportage signé jérôme
rhabiller je vais vous présenter tout de
suite nos invités dominique simonnot
bonsoir vous ce contrôleur général des
lieux de privation de liberté
j'accueille événement sénateurs stéphane
moreau dullier bonsoir bien bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur et l'ère des bouches du
rhône joaquim pueyo bonsoir soir
bienvenue à vous aussi maire
socialiste d'alençon ancien directeur
des prisons de fresnes et de fleury
mérogis et matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique qui restait à
mes côtés je reviens au point de départ
de notre débat ensuite on va vraiment
prendre le temps de parler de l'état de
nos prisons jarlier de surpopulation
canada d'aborder les thèmes de faux mais
cette politique initiale au coeur de
l'été ces images-là de de ce jeu
organisé dans la prison de fresnes est
ce que ça vous a et je voudrais parler
après mais je voudrais entendre le
politique d'abord est ce que ça vous a
choqué ses fins la rue de lille ah oui
totalement comme je pense la majorité
des français ça soulevé à mon sens
quelques quelques interrogations
notamment sur le sens de la peine en
fait qu'est ce qu'on attend de la prison
quel est son objectif
la première objectif il me semble que
c'est punir site privé la personne de
liberté pour protéger également la
société française est le message qui a
été envoyé c'est que la prison serait un
lieu de divertissement
est-ce que fondamentalement ça va avec
la punition je ne crois pas
derrière il ya la notion de
réintégration est-ce que ça passe par le
divertissement non ça passe par la
formation ça passe par le travail pour
préparer la personne qu'elle soit en
fait meilleure quand elle sort que quand
elle est arrivée donc forcément ça a été
très choquant et j'ajoute un fait je ne
pense pas que ça soit un phénomène isolé
on l'a vu à travers les réseaux sociaux
se multiplier des journées motocross
d'un côté des soirées pizzas voire même
fêté la fin du regagne les du ramadan à
la nuit sous pression justement de de
colomb thèse mais on a aussi la fête du
ramadan ou des glissades dans les
couloirs des prisons avec de la cua
tannique ça peut choquer effectivement
rida maison véritablement je pense
encore une fois que de la prison ne peut
pas être un lieu de divertissement l'âme
la même question pour vous joaquim pueyo
ces images effectivement c'était un jeu
il y avait du quartier y avait d'autres
d'autres
épreuves on va dire dans ce jeu est ce
que ça vous a également choqué moi ça
m'a ça m'a surpris parce que je crois
que on n'a pas mesuré l'impact des
images parce que ce qui a fait polémique
c'est karting en fait bon imaginez deux
activités à la place du parking je pense
qu'il n'y aurait pas autant de
polémiques et moi quand j'ai dirigé des
établissements on a mis en place des
expérimentations par exemple des détenus
caves et des autorisations de sortir
pour faire du marathon avec des
habitants de fresnes ça posait aucun
problème mais je pense d'ailleurs le
directeur lors que le reconnaît lui même
il l'a reconnu il ya quelques semaines
en disant que peut-être les épreuves
étaient pas forcément adapté et donc
c'est ça la question ensuite il faut se
poser pourquoi il ya eu c'est cette
journée est le directeur nous indiquer
que c'était une journée qui avait traité
très près et qui avait été préparé
depuis de longues semaines qui donnait
un sens également une journée de
solidarité
donc cet effet dans cet esprit et je
qu'il y avait de l'argent qui est revu
sociation alors moi je le dis monsieur
le sénateur on a eu effectivement des
détenus et qui ont fait du théâtre par
exemple et qui sont exprimés à travers
des activités théâtrales ou musicales et
qui se sont présentés à l'extérieur et
ça donnait également du sens à la peine
ce qui veut dire que la peine elle doit
effectivement écarté le détenu de la
société par rapport aux faits qu'il a
commis et puis elle a une deuxième
mission qui n'est peut-être pas
suffisamment mise en valeur c'est
réintégrer insérer le détenu et moi je
pense honnêtement que le la culture le
sport donc le verdissement dans le
divertissement il y en a évidemment
alors en ce cas là il faut supprimer la
télévision c'est un divertissement
également bon et donc si vous voulez le
divertissement ça dépend comment il les
fait comment il est encadré bon voilà
mais c'est vrai que alors je le dis je
le dis à mon avis les épreuves étaient
pas forcément adapté et ce qui m'a
étonné c'est le buzz et je me pose la
question pourquoi il ya eu autant de
buzz c'est à dire que peut-être
longuement mais on n'a pas encore
entendu dominique 6 me j'ai voulu
entendre les élus pour commencer parce
que dans la tribune que vous avez publié
dans le monde à la suite de ceux de
cette polémique vous avez parlé de
l'hypocrisie de nos élus pourquoi j'ai
trouvé absolument oui très hypocrite que
des élus
en l'occurrence des députés enfin bon
peu importe qui quels élus connaissent
très bien ce qui se passe en prison les
conditions de détention de la prison qui
s'il avait relu la loi aurait pu lire
que la prison doit effectivement être
une sanction mais offrir également des
activités récréatives ludique pourquoi
la prison ça n'est plus ce travail est
avec un chapeau à un capuchon sur la
tête et
est une aube
grise comme avant une tenue
pénitentiaire où vous me dites que la
loi autorise une activité difficile au
monde en moyenne celle le dis très
clairement et elle dit ça pour quoi
parce que en prison on ne fait pas que
pleurer non monsieur on me dit ça non
mais parfois on peut rire et je pense
que ce qui a choqué alors les deux
premiers qui ont des délais sont des
gens qui sont pas particulièrement à
gauche de l'échiquier politique
le garde des sceaux embrayé ça fait un
buzz je pense qu'il y avait rien d'autre
à faire moi je suis rentré de vacances
chômage a répondu à 40 interviews là
dessus j'étais étonné moi-même pourquoi
le kart je crois que ce qui a choqué
c'est de voir les détenus rire voyez
autant que le kart bien son nom va
supprimer les films comiques mais oui
prison il a des ciné clubs représentés
ici prix des rêves d'or qui viennent la
fine bouche il ya des niches aucun
centime c'est intéressant que ce soit
l'activité karting kick et qui a son
poids était était choquant pour les gens
pour il ya des chevaux qui rentrant des
chevaux et moi je vois la détient il ya
des ja dvt oui il ya des séances de vtt
il ya des séances d'escaladé parce que
parce que
de mépris de classe c'est à dire qu on
aurait projeté des films
qu'elle est destinée à élever leur
grandeur d'âme n'y aurait pas eu ce
souci là on les voit faire les cons et
se marrer sur sur des cartes en faut
rappeler quand même que l'événement il
organisé par un collectif qui a déjà
organisé des événements de ce type n'est
pas en prison forcément mais avec des
forces de l'ordre avec des jeunes des
quartiers l'idée c'est de se faire
parler des institutions et et la
population est lasse avaient été des
jeunes des quartiers des détenus et des
gardiens de prison mais si c'est
personnel pénitentiaire ces secteurs
donc en l'idée c'est vrai que le code
pénal précise que l'ami l'on sanctionne
mais doit aussi favoriser la réinsertion
dans une cité de dialogue et de
compétition résonné entre ces gens là on
peut imaginer que ça s'inscrit dans ce
cadre là après l'activité karting et
choc moi je pense qu'il ya une forme de
mépris de classe on est toujours en
france à dire que la prison est trop
molle pour les pauvres trop dur pour les
riches j'exagère vous allez juger ça
démago mais quand c'est des pauvres et
qu'ils se mettent à s'amuser eh ben
c'est que la prison va pas ça tous fous
quand quand c'est des riches qui sont en
prison qu'on est ministre ou qu'on est
dimanche et il faut qu'on les 100
dollars comme il a été ministre il peut
pas rester en prison aux idées vieux les
conditions des tensions c'est quand même
difficile et le curseur change selon la
population incarcérée et moi je trouve
que on en a un exemple là avec cette
affaire de quartier tout dépend comment
l'activité d'origine est sûr c'est qu'il
est invité à organiser avec derek on
veut respecter on a vu effectivement
dans les établissements pénitentiaires
par exemple je me souviens qu'on avait
organisé un tournoi de ping pong à
nanterre et j'avais un surveillant qui
était un très bon positive dit mais
j'aimerais bien rencontrer le finaliste
il a rencontré le finaliste et ça donne
une chance oui la gagner et ensuite les
détenus ont respecté cet agent design
est vraiment brillant je pense que c'est
pas nouveau les activités dans les
prisons françaises on le fait depuis de
nombreuses années tout dépend comment
s'organiser et puis je pense quand vous
avez un service pénitentiaire
d'insertion et probation qui met en
place des activités culturelles des
activités sportives lorsque vous avez
des talismans qui travaillent laissons
un petit peu l'initiative locale
également nous en ferons tout est
concentré tout est dirigé duo il ya des
pays comme l'allemagne par exemple ou
les établissements pénitentiaires
dépendant de landes où il ya des yat il
ya même des expérimentations qui sont
faites et moi je crois beaucoup à
l'expérimentation là c'était peut-être
une expérimentation les images ont fait
flop c'est vrai c'est peut-être qu'on a
mal évalué l'impact de ces images je
pense que la polémique est derrière nous
il faut plutôt réfléchir sur les
conditions de détention et comment
donner du sens à l'appel et ce à deux
problèmes et devront bien sûr mais c'est
pour ça qu'on a organisé ce débat ici
ses fans le rudulier effectivement vous
il ya aussi l'image des prisons où
l'image de la paix m
donner la parole là dessus mais d'abord
on écoute le garder son écoute le
ministre de la justice eric
dupond-moretti il était le 23 août
dernier donc on est après la publication
la révélation de ces images il est en
visite à fleury mérogis écouter avec
dupond moretti pour moi la prison c'est
la sanction et la réinsertion dans ces
images que j'ai vues il n'y a ni
sanction ni
réinsertion et pardon de vous dire que
je pense à certains gamins qui voit ces
images et qui disent la prison lol la
prison elle doit avoir un effet
dissuasif
ses fans le rudulier est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec le garde des sceaux
mais pour une fois je suis entièrement
d'accord avec ces propos je trouve que
c'est très équilibré c'est justement la
question du sens de la peine mais tout à
l'heure effectivement on pense à l'image
qu'à renvoyer en fait la prison
vis-à-vis de la société mais aussi aux
victimes aux familles de victimes en
fonction d'ailleurs de la sélection des
candidats à ce fameux koltès à
polémiquer sur deux deux profils qui
apparemment avaient commis des délits
très graves au niveau de la société donc
j'ai j'annonce avec la culture il
faudrait modules et l'accès
et puis il ya une différence entre eux
une pièce de théâtre puisque c'est la
culture ça élève aussi d'individus la
culture le sport l'avait entièrement
raison pin pour collecter ces séquences
de divertissement lors le karting ou
autres qui à mon sens on est allé trop
loin et effectivement je suis d'accord
avec avec le ministre il y avait là ni
sanction de dissuasion dominique c'est
ce que
si les j'aimerais reprendre les propos
de eric dupond-moretti si les activités
récréatives sont trop sympa grosso modo
la prison n'aura plus son effet
dissuasif qu'est-ce que vous répondrez
ça j'ai pas entendre ses arguments non
moi j'ai très mal parce que je pense
qu'il aurait pas eu les images y aurait
rien du tout et qu'il se passe tous les
jours en prison je suis sûr il se
passait des activités récréatives et
ludique qui choquerait également
l'opinion où le garde des sceaux qui par
parenthèse c'est très bien ce qui se
passe je
quand on dit que la loi a prévu des
activités récréatives c'est parce qu'on
n'est pas obligé tout le temps de
s'ennuyer en prison il ya des gens
thierry en prison est las de voir je
trouve des surveillants et des détenus
ensemble qui rigolaient qui se taper sur
l'épaule je trouvais que c'était et bien
pour une fois vous êtes entré dans des
prisons monsieur jules vous avez vu
l'ambiance moi j'y ai passé là je sors
d'une prison je peux vous dire que
l'ambiance n'est pas celle là les les
surveillants nous disent on est dans une
détresse horrible tellement ya de monde
et c'est la première fois que j'entends
des détenus me le dire les surveillants
ils pètent souvent les plombs il ya de
la violence au bout du diable à ce qu'il
devienne le fou ou électro ou me dit il
ya besoin d'événements la cocotte minute
explose passons des soupapes voilà on a
coulé non mais freine après je freine
ses dribbles friend le discours mais il
ya aussi le respect de l'autorité
l'administration pénitentiaire c'est
l'autorité mais elle a prévenu si on
mélange les choses où est la frontière
pour le pôle prévu est-ce que
fondamentalement on a vu baisser les
taux de récidive après le kart non tu
appelles 4 et ce genre là après ce genre
d'activité c'est rien la date de 2009
royal d'organes
force est de constater que le taux de
récidive n'a pas chuté pour autant le
taux de récidive ne peut pas chuter tant
que nos prisons maison d'arrêt sont
surpeuplées et ça se sent % c'est un
autre sujet
bêtise dans lesquels on laisse les gens
vivent à redon de reprendre la main ses
activités récréatives on peut les on
peut les organisé depuis très longtemps
en prison bien sûr enfin si vous voulez
on parle surtout d'activités éducatives
c'est ça qui est l'essentiel oui mais il
ya les deux mots dans la loi mais dans
certaines activités éducatives ya
effectivement des activités récréatives
lorsque par exemple vous omettez mettez
en place par exemple un atelier d'échec
est déjà arrivé c'est à la fois éducatif
mais c'est également récréatif aussi et
les jeux d'échecs s'est pas c'est pas
anodin dans une prison bon ça c'est
intéressant quand même comme activité si
vous voulez dans un temps de détention
il faut l'organiser on a malheureusement
trop de personnes détenues qui ne font
rien en prison et donc il a peut-être on
en parlera dans le débat il ya des
expériences en espagne où il ya
effectivement des unités des modules de
respect où on donne un peu plus
d'autonomie aux détenus nouveau leurs
cellules dans la journée mais il ya
également une obligation d'activité moi
j'ai fait une expérience possible
dominique simonnot le sait quand j'ai
dirigé fleury mérogis j'avais souhaité
que pour les courtes peines ont eu une
unité spéciale pour mettre en place des
programmes d'insertion et je lirai
obligatoire les détenus devaient choisir
des activités s'adonner à la prison un
autre sens des surveillants me disais
nous n'a plus de problème d'autorité
parce que le détenu il a un programme
qui fait du sport il va à l'école il ya
des activités de loisirs aussi parfois
et puis il prépare sa sortie et ça c'est
au tous le problème de fond mais pour
faire cela il faut absolument que le
principe de l'encellulement individuel
soit appliquée ça fait des dizaines
d'années des hors la loi avait évité à
thé voté par nos prédécesseurs au xixème
siècle qu'on l'a jamais appliquée on a
toujours reporté l'enseignement
individuel quel sens peut-on donner à
une détention lorsque vous mettez deux
ou trois d'études onuci l'une 9 mètres
carrés les conséquences psychologiques
le stress la santé les violences et là
autour man au problème de la peine et
après on s'étonne qu'un détenu sort plus
violent de la prison qu'il y rentrer on
va en parler évidemment de la
surpopulation carcérale justement grâce
à quentin calmer tout de suite pour pour
commencer pour faire un point précis la
situation actuelle en france en terme de
places de prison alors le message de la
justice est très transparent sur le
sujet on a trouvé un grand nombre de
données statistiques sur le site du
moulin la justice sont d'ailleurs ces
données réactualisées tous les mois
voici les dernières elles datent du
début du mois d'août on compte en france
alors un groupe qui réunit pour le
ministère beaucoup de monde mais c'est
80 7293 personnes écrouées en fait 71
milles sont détenus les autres disposent
d'aménagement de peine un chiffre donc
71 milles qui est à comparer aux nombres
de places opérationnelles en france on
en a 60 1719 au 1er août donc selon ses
informations cela donne un taux de
suroccupation carcéral de 118% et cm 140
% en moyenne dans les 80 une maison
d'arrêt est là où il ya des personnes
qui sont en détention provisoire ou qui
jouent à qui il reste une peine à finir
devant jeunes commencent ce taux
évoluent ces derniers temps ce dernières
décennies alors là encore on dispose de
données statistiques grâce à une somme
la justice depuis 2005 la courbe bleue
que vous voyez c'est celle du nombre de
détenus en france on voit le chiffre la
courbe rouge parlons c'est ça le lion de
détenus en france on voit le le chiffre
qui chute comme ça en 2020 avec les
libérations anticipées et les amène à
des aménagements de peines liées à la
crise de la crise sanitaire avec les
ducaux vide c'est le seul moment vous
voyez thomas ou le chiffre passe sous la
barre du nombre de places disponibles
car ce que l'on retient c'est que l'on
de prisonniers en france augmentent de
façon constante depuis le début des
années 2000 tout comme le nombre de
places de prison
1 avec autour de 50 milles en 2005 pour
atteindre 60 mille donc en 2022 avec une
forte augmentation voyez là-bas un qui
qui monte autour de 2010 sous le canal
de nicolas sarkozy c'est avec l'actuel
président de la république est bien en
2017 emmanuel macron avait fait la
promesse de construire quinze mille
nouvelles places de prison c'est pendant
la campagne
un objectif que le gouvernement pourrait
atteindre finalement en deux
quinquennats on est à la moitié du gain
en ce moment le gouvernement a ainsi
annoncé un deuxième volet du plan 15000
places de prison c'était en avril
2021 le gouvernement qui parle de
construire 1500 places net par an sur
une période de 10 ans en comptant donc
aussi les prisons qu'il faut fermer et
le gouvernement qui part d'un objectif
ambitieux quand on compare un ce sont
ces arguments à ce qui s'est fait entre
1986 et 2000 16 ou le rythme était
dit-il de mille places supplémentaires
par an en moyenne toute la difficulté
thomas et c'est un peu le noeud du
problème c'est de trouver de nouveaux
lieux pour installer des prisons est les
riverains et les élus locaux étant
extrêmement frileux al'annonce de tout
nouveau projet effectivement merci quand
un stéphane de rue du lieu c'est vrai
que pour un élu local c'est pas évident
de faire accepter peut-être aux
habitants la population la construction
d'une nouvelle prison sur son territoire
c'est très juste mais je mais je pense
qu'il l'état devrait
accompagner les communes les
collectivités avec des mesures
incitatives j'envoie de 2,3 sortent
d'une part
encourager la construction de centres de
détention par des mesures financières
des dotations de fonctionnement pour les
communes sur une majoration de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement ou
encore l'exonération dans le cadre des
communes qui sont trop car ans pour
certains logements sociaux l'exonération
partielle ou totale d'une pénalité
financière qui peut parfois aller
jusqu'à 500 mille six cent mille euros
par an mais si on n'a pas ces mesures
d'accompagnement et ces mesures
incitatives je crains fort que c'est un
peu le serpent qui se mord la queue
effectivement et on ira de recours en
recours on en parlait tout à l'heure
parce que il ya de la part de la
population une réticence très forte et
là il ya de la pédagogie et un
accompagnement à faire au niveau de la
population sans cela je crains fort que
les objectifs chiffrés quel que soit le
gouvernement ne soit pas rempli parce
qu'on n'est jamais à l'abri d'une
procédure et d'un contentieux
administratif en matière d'urbanisme
parce qu'il s'agit bien de cela
un centre de détention il faut déposer
un permis et on sait que ces procédures
là peuvent être très longues peuvent
durer trois ans cinq ans voire même 10
ans si on va jusqu'au conseil d'état
dominique simonnot et ce qui est une
alternative est ce parce que ça semble
la solution la plus évidente ya
surpopulation carcérale donc
construisons plus de places de port sont
d'abord vous savez à la fin de l'année
dernière enfin 2021 a ouvert en grande
pompe la prison de lutterbach savez par
qui elle avait été promise et quand par
michèle alliot marie en 2009 donc
laissons tomber je pense que en tout cas
là on verra pas de solution avant dix
ans il faut construire de les nouvelles
prisons prévues par le gouvernement dont
on ne sait pas bien parce que c'est tout
un jeune bonneteau ces histoires de
construction de prisons
oui en plaine orientale est ce qu'on
parle des places prévues déjà par le
gouvernement d'avant qui prenait déjà
sur celle du gouvernement n'avance c'est
sûr qu'on a du mal et moi je voudrais
qu'on m'explique pourquoi en allemagne
où on b on privilégie la prison hors les
murs c'est à dire les alternatives à
l'enfermement pourquoi on a 20 millions
d'habitants en plus en allemagne mais on
a vingt mille 15 mille détenus de moins
et je crois pas que l'allemagne soit un
pays particulièrement laxistes
simplement ils ont courageusement tout
miser sur une courage politique
d'assumer de mise et la prison hors les
murs la peine hors les murs avec travail
d'intérêt général placement extérieur
effectivement travail d'intérêt général
sursis probatoire détention à domicile
électroniques sont sont les peines
alternatives on va dire ça comme ça il
ya on a trouvé ce chiffre qui date de
l'an dernier quatorze mille cinq cents
personnes placées sous surveillance
électronique
en france ces fameux régulier c'est une
alternative une solution aussi a pas que
la construction de nouvelles places il
ya les alternatives je vais mettre le
pavé dans la mare il faut aussi il faut
aussi regarder la population carcérale
ça c'est le chiffre du ministère
l'intérieur de la justice il ya 25% de
détenus étrangers
qui sont incarcérés en france ça veut
dire mais très près d'un détenu sur
quatre faut avoir le courage un moment
donné est-ce que nous avons vocation ou
la france à maintenir ces détenus en
france je pense qu'ils doivent exécuter
leur peine dans les pays étrangers alors
on va opposer les laissez passer
consulaires est ce ce chantage qui peut
être fait à voir là le courage aussi à
un moment donné de dire ben écoutez les
visas comme avait commencé à le faire
emmanuel macron en ce qui concerne
l'algérie désir mais ont réduit le
nombre de visas ou encore on fait bien
de rassurer avec les pays d'origine en
match je pense ce serait une couche une
solution à court terme qui libérerait
les places de prison parce que quand on
voit la politique
en tout cas
pénitentiaire qui est mise en oeuvre et
dont on prononce des peines en fonction
d'une arme au nombre de places de prison
qui reste il ya eu des circulaires de
monsieur dupont méroïte il est en train
de nous dire que s'il ya plus de places
en prison les gens vont prononcer il ya
eu des incitations au niveau du
ministère de la justice c'était la
circulaire de décembre
2021 ou ont demandé de porter une
attention justement à des peines
alternatives et que la prison soit le
dernier au sort nous les gars n'étaient
une circulaire c'était c'était une
c'était une c'était une lettre adressée
par le directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire à tous les chefs de cour
et durée diction disant je vous en
supplie on ne peut plus gérer on ne
pouvait donc c'est la prison va exploser
ça confirme bien ce que je dis ou ont
porté attention sur le fait qu'on ne
pouvait plus accueillir de nouveaux
détenus
donc forcément le juge avant de
prononcer la peine avait en mémoire
cette lettre joachim fuiraient
m'exprimer parce que
il faut rénover le parc pénitentiaire
on peut pas laisser en l'état le parc
sur tous les leviers de maison d'arrêt
mais l'afp donc la reine vous étiez
l'epad le directeur de fresnes en 2000
en 2000 j'avais demandé la rénovation
d'établissements en 2010 donc ça fait 23
ans quand tant de ces images
ça fait la garde des sceaux de l'époque
elisabeth guigou était venu à fresnes
fait visiter et elle avait lancé
effectivement le programme de rénovation
des grandes prisons parisiennes la santé
fleury et freine la santé ça a été fait
fleury s'est terminée et il restait
friend 22 ans après deuxièmement je
crois qu'il est quand même un autre moi
je préfère qu'il y ait plus de places de
prison et moi détenus le taux
d'incarcération en espagne par exemple
il est plus important qu'en france plus
important mais il ya autant eu autant de
place que deux prisonniers quasiment au
portugal c'est la même chose en
allemagne c'est encore différent demain
c'est donc différent que c'est très
différent tel combat mais ce que je
voudrais dire également la justice est
l'un des points donc ça veut dire quoi
par sa femme juste pour bien comprendre
on ne les juge ne prononce pas
suffisamment de ces alternatives à la
détention c'est de plus en plus quand
même fait honnête quand vous regardez le
nombre de personnes condamnées à des
sursis mise à l'épreuve cent trente
mille par an 130 milles 140 mines oui
enfin c'est fini c'est par l'approbation
probatoire eux il ya quand même
peut-être n'y a pas suffisamment de semi
liberté peut être compris à faire des
efforts sur la libération conditionnelle
ce qui veut dire un travail énorme pour
libérer ce conditions il faut vérifier
les conditions de vie des détenus
l'extérieur si la compagnie il faut un
service d'insertion conséquent donc
c'est vrai que ça s'est compliqué il
faut jouer sur les trois tableaux par
pénitentiaire il faut le rénover parce
que il faut absolument arriver à
l'enseignement individuel je pense qu'il
faut quand même respecter l'autorité
judiciaire
on va pas dire au juge ah ben vous
pouvez pas mettre cette taille là parce
qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de moyens
le gouvernement doit donner les moyens
c'est ce que fait garder soit
actuellement on peut le critiquer mais
il a bien compris quand même qu'il
fallait davantage de moyens pour la
justice il va le faire pour les
magistrats la pénitentiaire 7,42 pour
cent du budget de la justice il faut
renforcer les moyens et je pense que si
effectivement on arrive à ce principe on
aurait beaucoup moins de conséquences au
niveau des détenus les plus fragiles
notamment mais également au niveau des
personnels le personnel sous l'autorité
et compliqué actuellement quand vous
ouvrez une cellule avec trois détenus
compliqué il ya des problèmes de 2,2
qaïda et des problèmes de violence
lorsque est ce que c'est normal d'après
vous qu'une personne condamnée pour
trafic de
stupéfiants continue son trafic à la
prison est ce que c'est normal qu'à
détenu qui a commis des violences liées
cros et à la prison il continue à faire
ces violences en prison est ce que c'est
normal
puisque les gardiens n'ont pas les
moyens de l'empêcher c'est ça mais parce
qu'il ya trop de détenus par rapport au
nombre de gardiens qui étiquette qui
sont en poste vous aurez pas oublié
alors ils sont côte à relier le petit
avantage que produit bon de shit sur les
détenus la potel poté nice a même ch je
peux comprendre avaya beaucoup de ben
oui oui je peux le dire sans domicile de
réalité
vous de regarder la réalité en face moi
je la vois en face chaque fois que je
vais en prison et je sais ça comme tout
le monde donc vous pouvez donc peut-être
qu'on laisse le trafic se dérouler cl
c'est très choquant chesnais dit l'axé
bien si j'ai dit que la réalité elle est
celle là je voudrais dire pourquoi parce
que vous donnez pas parce que une
personne détenue arrivent en prison
condamné à une peine de prison ferme on
devrait travailler sur sa réinsertion en
fonction des faits qu'il a commis
quelqu'un qui est violente mettons en
place des programmes par rapport à la
violence quelqu'un qui a commis
effectivement les infractions parce
qu'il était alcoolique travaillons
autour de fait de ce sujet là et là on
le fait pas suffisamment dans les yeux
déjà pas les moyens pour la peinture sur
les murs un jardin dans les pays
nordiques il ya très longtemps qu'ils
ont mis en place des programmes quand
vous allez dans les établissements pour
mineurs au danemark j'en ai visité aux
pays bas et en belgique ils ont à des
programmes nous si on le fait quand même
pour les mineures mais j'avais fait un
rapport sur les mineurs et des
programmes quand même et des programmes
très structuré et qui donne du sens à la
fois la privation de liberté parce qu'il
faut les écarter pendant une durée
certaine mais également l'intérêt d'une
société c'est que le détenu puisse se
réhabiliter et puissent s'insérer en
respectant nos lois c'est pas facile
c'est difficile alors mais ça donne du
sens donné la parole débat passionnant
on va notamment parlé de l'état un là on
a beaucoup parlé de réinsertion mais
vraiment l'état des murs quand l'état
des prisons étaient les conditions de
vie des détenus mais comme je voudrais
vous entendre sur cette histoire de
trafic de drogue et de finalement
principe de réalité dont nous parle
dominique simonnot ben ça calme les
détenus pour regarder les choses non on
peut pas on peut pas dire le sauveur ce
qu'il dit c'est ce qui est interdit et
la réalité c'est dehors des murs de la
prison doit être su également interdits
en prison au sommet du shit aux détenus
le gx réalité de ce bénéfique pour les
deux pays où j'ai mal j'ai mal compris
aux mains des fai un effet bénéfique
pour le calme qui règne dans la prison
parce que ça calme mais ils vont parler
mais à les écouter on sait les dégâts
que procure le shit sur eux mais sa
drogue comme vous dites sur la santé ce
rapport après pour quand ils seront
sortis en attendant jean mais c'est un
phénomène quand même parce que moi je
rejoins ce petit effectivement ça doit
être un processus de réhabilitation
il faut donner 10 reinhard la réalité il
faut donner toutes les arrivées je suis
je suis assez d'accord sur la dernière
partie votre intervention toutes les
armes pour que le détenu quand ils
sortent puisse être au plus vite
réintégrer dans la société qu'on lui
apprennent un métier qu'on les ducs il
passe des diplômes en prison deux faces
du sport
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
le trafic de drogue la radicalisation
dans les prisons l'escaladé de la
violence les détenus mais on mais selon
john stefano des joints par la presse qu
on donne est-ce que alors là je vais pas
pointer tel ou tel pouvoir politique
mais vous nous dites non les moyens
parce que vous dites c'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire sauf qu'on n'a jamais
vraiment donné les moyens
l'administration pénitentiaire par les
barrières mais ça c'est un 16-4 aux
demandes pour accéder à tout ce que vous
dites s'il ya trop de monde pour accéder
à la culture
c'est un cas c'est un constat qui à mon
avis était partagé par tous notamment
dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle où il fallait mettre les
moyens au niveau de la justice tant au
niveau de la magistrature par des
greffiers les pages où j'ai l'espoir que
ces noms notamment selon lui nicolas
sarkozy c'est pas très populaire de
donner de l'argent aux prisons pour
favoriser la question quand on regarde
le le le combien coûte la justice en
france au regard d'autres pays européens
je pense qu on est cinq fois ou six fois
entre guillemets moins important en
termes de coûts tout en termes de
dépenses sur la justice que par exemple
l'allemagne donc effectivement il faut
de l'investissement pour de nouveaux
centres de détention mais aussi du
personnel qualifié et lancinant
individuel est une réponse je veux à mon
sens
je voudrais faire une observation c'est
à dire alors à quand j'étais en
résidence mathieu qu'on vous entende
gérer justice sur le c en est vraiment
la traîne par rapport aux pays européens
où vous êtes membre d'un parti qui a été
au pouvoir
pourquoi j'ai fait 7000 places où la
justice est un thème qui est largement
entonné notamment en campagne électorale
pourquoi cgem un sujet prioritaire pour
budgétairement pourquoi ça n'a jamais
été ce budget a été le seul a été un
période 2007-2012 prévenait on a créé on
a créé 7000 places de prison il ya eu un
effondrement souffrent soit le monde
puisque j'ai fait les chiffres on était
à 1283 places de prison est donc
effectivement cheval en termes de
l'effort
l'effort qui avaient été portées entre
2007 et 2012 et bien s'est effondré sous
les quinquennat de de françois hollande
et de manuel martinez des esprits mais
quand j'ai été élue députée
effectivement j'avais demandé à l'époque
mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas tout suivi
je reconnais j'avais demandé au
gouvernement de créer immédiatement va
immédiatement
plus de dix mille places bon on n'a pas
été suivi dans un premier temps ensuite
effectivement il ya eu des places de
créer mais un peu un peu tardivement moi
je vois le parc pénitentiaire tout
simplement suite si vous voulez
l'opinion publique faut voir comment
comment les habitants réagissent quand
dans les quartiers parce que je suis
maire également je suis président d'une
communauté urbaine quand vous avez
effectivement des personnes qui sont
écroués pour trafic de stups qui
ressorte et qui recommencent leurs
activités mais on se pose des questions
sur effectivement l'efficacité de la
peine et donc c'est une question de fond
qui font ce qu'il faut se poser moi je
vois effectivement japon on travaille
avec le procureur parce que je crois que
c'est bien que les élus locaux également
travail ces questions et on a mis en
place un comité très intéressant locale
avec le procureur la police des services
sociaux pour prendre pour réfléchir sur
les meilleures méthodes mais c'est vrai
que c'est des questions qu'on doit se
poser ça veut dire que si on veut
travailler sur l'arrestation s'est pas
uniquement que la sphère de la prison
c'est la sphère de la société également
dans son entier allait il nous reste
moins de dix minutes vraiment on va
parler de l'état
l'état des constructions de l'état des
murs l'état de ses prisons et je vous
propose d'entendre pour commencer la
pression du groupe elle est fier à
l'assemblée mme at-il pas noël était le
25 août sur france inter on est toujours
dans dans la foulée de ce scandale koh
lanta est deuxième des choses qui
devrait choquer tous les français c'est
la condamnation par la cour européenne
des des droits humains de la france en
2020 pour conditions inhumaines dans six
prisons et freine n'est pas en reste
puisque freine c'est une prison qui a
été ouvert en 1898 qui est très vétuste
dans lequel il ya une surpopulation
carcérale très forte et par ailleurs des
détenus qui vivent avec des rats des
puits
dominique simonnot je rappelle que vous
êtes contrôle général de les lieux de
privation de liberté pour vous les cas
les plus chauds parce que freine c'est
la prison qui est dans le pire état en
france non moi ce qui m'a dévasté c'est
toulouse seysses et gradignan est ce que
vous j'ai vu des gens puisque j'ai passé
longtemps avec eux dans les cellules des
gens enfermés à trois avec 0.8 mètres
carrés d'espacé vital par personne
puisque nous quand on y va en mesure
tout je me suis juché sur le frigo le
type qui dormait au sol il y avait un
matelas au sol deux lits superposés
il respirait les bébés cafard avec la
poussière elle met trimestre de nimègue
dans les narines et dans les oreilles il
ya quand même un monsieur qui a eu à une
infection de l'oreille un cafard mort à
toulouse
et ils restent dans ces cellules 22
heures sur 24 comment voulez vous qu'ils
sortent dans un état normal comment
comment est-ce qu'on veut que mais
n'importe qui de nous deviendrais fou
là-dedans de rien q rien que de pas
pouvoir se dépenser et il ya de la
violence c'est sûr que ça engendre la
violence engendre la violence entre
détenus et entre détenus et surveillants
forcément et c'est horrible à voir les
surveillants moi je
je parle beaucoup avec eux ils ont une
vie mais horrible l'attend stefano
régulier c'est intéressant
votre très bien sûr mais aussi les
conséquences c'est à dire
l'objectif l'un des objectifs de la
prison c'est effectivement la
réinsertion et qu'à la fin de la peine
la personne ne soit plus un danger pour
la société dans ces conditions là c'est
plus difficile on est bien c'est que ces
mêmes je pense ça procure l'effet
inverse bon il accéléré donc on en
revient à la question des moyens
pourquoi ils ont dû - éditions mathieu
tout à l'heure
un vaste plan de réhabilitation on parle
toujours de place nette mais c'est très
bien pour l'encellulement individuel
mais il ya aussi un vaste plan de
réhabilitation qui doit être enclenché
le plus rapidement possible parce qu'il
en va derrière de la réintégration dans
l'ascèse de la réputation c'est d'études
qui à juste titre comme vous le dites et
votre témoignage et est assez probant
vont devenir des dangers pour la société
alors sorti parce que c'est un peu leur
double peine alors ça devienne la double
peine un petit blanc c'est lui ment une
précision quand même ça concerne
uniquement les maisons d'arrêt parce que
le numerus clausus il existe dans les
établissements pour peine des centres
détention et les maisons centrales sont
pas un son pop îles à sion
c'est bien de le rappeler et dans les
établissements pénitentiaires pour peine
il ya effectivement des des projets très
intéressants on a également mis en place
des régimes progressif dans certains
établissements donc c'est comme est
intéressant de rappeler mme
effectivement le problème de la
surpopulation concerne les maisons
d'arrêt et des personnes qui reste très
peu de temps réalité est-ce que c'est
pas encore pire parce qu'ils ont fait
était encore jugé donc c'est sont
présumés innocents jusqu'à moi je
préférais que quelqu'un qui est condamné
par exemple qui reste onze mois ou 12
mois en prison je préfère qu'il aille en
semi liberté avec un projet là ça donne
plus de sens il est quand même privé de
liberté mais aussi l'est pas parce qu'il
ya des détenus qui sont pas dangereux
pour le public ton équipe à sous réserve
qu'ils puissent oui mais c'est à manier
avec avec précision au cas par cas parce
qu'on va avoir des semi liberté qui vont
récidiver avant même d'avoir été c'est
aussi une réalité où sont les conditions
de détention on connaît toutes les
conséquences bon effectivement les les
trafics le qaïda qui se renforce
considérablement le caïdat ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire bien caïds qui vous
avez des détenus qui mènent et détention
dans les cellules et le surveillant il
ya des difficultés pour de mettre de
l'ordre parce que dans les prisons si on
veut donner dix ans il faut qu'elle soit
ordonnée qui est de l'autorité et
quelquefois y en a pas n'y a pas de
hordes diable dans le sens positif du
terme quand je mets horde sens positif
donc il faut quand même absolument et
moi je suis d'accord avec le
gouvernement lorsqu'il annonce un
programme pour mettre suffisamment de
place dans les prisons enfin dans en
france il n'y a pas suffisamment de
place ensuite on peut mieux travailler
et donc des conditions de travail sont
effectivement difficile dans les maisons
d'arrêt et c'est peut-être pour ça
également que quelquefois il ya des
surveillants eh bien ils se découragent
pas ce que vous savez comme il ya des
agressions enfants en france dans les
prisons sur les surveillants 5000
agression par an plus de 5000 autant
entre détenus et à dire plus de 10000
agression est ce que c'est normal que
dans un lieu qui représente la sûreté et
la sécurité est autant de violence julie
non vous nous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
ce n'est pas nouveau si je ne me trompe
dominique simonnot il ya eu en fera que
c'était en l'an 2000 un rapport
parlementaire oui le titre du rapport
c'était prison une humiliation les mains
comment vous expliquez qui se soit pas
passé grand chose je mets des chargés de
placer m'obsède parce que tu dis tout le
monde là le peuple les représentants du
peuple tout le monde était d'accord en
ce sens mais c'est pas possible ce qu'on
leur fait vivre il faut que ça change
tout le monde s'était juré que ça allait
changer et puis tout le monde l'a oublié
et je vous donne un exemple de l'idiotie
administrative qui fait que les gamins
qui sont incarcérés
savait qu'ils ont cours pendant les
vacances scolaires il n'y a pas de cours
pendant les vacances scolaires vient
vous est incarcéré aux états un gamin
vous êtes dans un centre éducatif vous
n'avez pas il n'y a pas de statut de
profs spécial prison et il n'ya pas les
heures de cours alors que c'est des
enfants je pense sur qui on devra mettre
au contraire le paquet pour apprendre à
vivre mais il n'y a pas
laissé le statut des professeurs avec
les vacances scolaires cessé parce qu'un
départ est je dépends de l'éducation
nationale ça paraisse qu'il paye une
erreur collective oui c'est que
effectivement budget de la justice est
passée
sur le second plan parfois on a dit
sécurité moyens renfort niveau la police
etc en oubliant qu'à une chaîne pénale
dérivés et que la justice elle rend
forcément la justice au monde au nom du
peuple français convenez quand même que
le gouvernement fait des efforts au
niveau de miss à la justice quand même
nom mais là c'est très sérieux guardian
annonce effectivement une rémunération
est ce qui est des magistrats une
évolution du budget donc ils le font
quand même on est très vigilant vous
savez au sénat sur la loi de règlement
donc on fait attention entre mais les
annonces
prévisionnel budgétaire prévisionnel et
la réalité donc on sera on portera une
attention toute particulière assumer la
responsabilité d'adp ya 30 ans dans
trente ans
deux ans vous faire porter au
gouvernement actuel la responsabilité de
la gauche et de la droite de ces vingt
ou trente dernières années peu et fait
partie une énorme partie du budget de la
pénitentiaire est absorbée par le
remboursement des intérêts quand on a
construit des prisons en partenariat
public privé mais je pense une prise qui
ouvre un autre prise de conscience
globale quand même actuellement et je
pense que le gouvernement a quand même
mis en place un programme ambitieux il
foulera il faut le
solitaire
encore merci beaucoup merci à tous il
était passionnant ce débat bientôt dans
ce sens public voilà c'est la fin de
cette émission je vous donne rendez vous
demain 18h et 22h vous savez qu'on est
diffusée minimum à deux reprises sur
l'antenne de public sénat et puis demain
dans la matinale regardons signé reçoit
christophe béchu le ministre la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires je sais pas si on va lui
faire réécouter la chronique que vous
nous aviez proposé la semaine dernière
qu'il n'était pas très sympa pour lui
parler de chasse sans pouvoir lui parler
chasse aussi merci à tous encore une
fois c'est la fin de cette émission
salut à demain
[Musique]